foreign
[Music]
if you wanted to um you know go out
sometime you want to get a coffee now
yes now
I'll just hang on when I wake up well I
know I'm gonna be her name is Sadie
I mean I know this sounds crazy but I
think she might be the one
who goes along with you she really is
great you'll see
any word she goes to them I bet she
hasn't even seen your text she does
travel a lot for work go to her I'm
going to London
see you get it it's a grand romantic
gesture that is amazing mate 5 000 miles
to surprise a girl who you've only met
once especially if she's the one who
ghosted yeah
no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan all right
[Music]
where am I oh God you you have the wrong
guy I'm a former wait wait
[Music]
foreign
oh my God oh my God
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I saw the rock
you're the one who flew to London
it was a romantic gesture
this is bigger than you and me
it never occur to you they give you a
foreign asset trying to compromise your
mission
foreign
[Music]
trust me is that a joke